this is not a partisan moment this is a
moral moment in our country ultimately
not whether he's innocent or guilty this
is not a trial but ultimately has enough
questions be raised that we should not
move on to another candidate that was
Senator Spartacus in New Jersey saying
as you just heard it doesn't really
matter if Brett Kavanaugh is innocent or
if he's guilty
Democrats have spent so long attacking
him without tangible evidence that
really it's his obligation to just
submit and let his career and reputation
and family be destroyed you know for the
good of the country it's a moral
question Alan Dershowitz is retired
Harvard Law professor he's the author of
the best-selling the case against
impeaching Trump he is a reality check
on first principles and he joins us
tonight
do you think professor that that's a
fine stand it doesn't matter whether
he's innocent or guilty he should just
submit well it sounds very familiar when
I was in college that's what they said
about people who are accused of being
communist yes as a matter of the guilty
if somebody has accused you of being a
communist and you angrily responded and
said you're not and you don't have the
temperament to have the job and it's
just a job interview if you're getting
fired from being a professor after 40
years and what's the difference if
you're innocent or guilty somebody has
said you're a communist this goes all
the way back to the Inquisition
when they would call you in first and
make you testify and then they present
the evidence look once you're accused
the most heinous crime imaginable it
turns into a trial where you have due
process yes where the burden of proof is
on the other side where the evidence has
to be clear and convincing in America we
don't allow people to destroy other
people's reputations and careers based
on an inference of guilt the way the
ACLU now says the ACLU says we should
presume guilt not presume in after a
hundred years of defending due process
that's exactly what they're saying so
you are a liberal you have lived your
life in a liberal world you go to month
izv and you know liberals do any of them
ever say look I don't agree with
Kavanagh I hate Trump but I agree with
you that due process is worth preserving
are there liberals who feel that way I
found very very few of them for example
today 700 law professors assigned a
letter they asked me to sign that I
refused I wrote a dissent saying he now
no longer has the judicial temperament
well can you imagine if this were
liberal who had been appointed by a
liberal president who had been accused
and it would acted similarly I don't
think a single one of those professors
would have signed that letter they all
fail the shoe on the other foot test
senator Booker who I like and know is
just dead wrong this is all about
partisanship if the opposite was
happening and if it was the Democrats
who were putting up a candidate
everybody would behave in the opposite
way and so it is partisanship and I
think the framers of our Constitution
never intended the confirmation process
to look anything like I agree and I hope
that I would be honest enough to say so
I mean we defended our Franken on this
show whom I don't like personally and I
hate his politics but I think he got
Shafter for the same reason - yes he
deserves to be defended mm-hmm you wrote
or you were quoted in a recent piece
saying that Julie sweat nixed all a have
a legal obligation to withdraw her
previous statement what did you mean
yeah I've done some research now on it
and there are ethical and bar rules that
say that when you submit an affidavit
even to Congress and you later learn
that there are things in the affidavit
that are false you have a continuing
obligation to withdraw the affidavit you
cannot allow an affidavit to remain on
the record right if you have information
suggesting it's false and any reasonable
lawyer hearing her on television says
you can't any longer accept what's in
that affidavit she has to be
investigated independently of the
background check criminally investigated
to see if she deliberately and willfully
with or without the aid of anybody else
made a decision just to frame somebody
for something that he had nothing to do
with the evidence seems to suggest they
never knew each other they were years
apart they were operating in different
circles it wouldn't surprise me if an
FBI investigation proved they never met
each other and if that turns out to be
the fact she belongs in a court of law
being prosecuted with a presumption of
innocence
yes offender but if the evidence shows
that she committed perjury prison Wow I
know why because it's important to
protect people against being raped but
it's so important to protect people
against being deliberately and willfully
falsely accused of rape that is a very
very serious crime and
tend not to pay as much attention to
false deliberately false I'm not talking
about people make oh I understand
they're forgetting but deliberately
false frame-ups of rape have to be taken
serious and they're not I happen to know
Alan Dershowitz professor thank you very
much thank you great to see you